so I am about 5 foot 8 inches and a
little bit that's not really sure it's
not but it's also not super tall no
one's ever packed me in the street and
thought there goes a really tall guy and
being a little bit shorter I face
certain assumptions from people in the
gym one is that I can't be quite as
strong as my taller brethren reason
being that they have bigger frame unless
they've got more space to fill out with
muscle more muscle equals more power the
other assumption is that because I'm
smaller it's easy as me to fill out the
frame but I do have therefore yeah I'm
kind of cheating when I look strong
because I don't have to work as hard or
as much protein so the truth and the
dorsum acacia turns out there's a bit
more to it than that
[Music]
so you've watched my other videos or
read my Probert then you'll know there's
more to strengths than just the amount
of muscle we have on your phone things
like muscle fiber recruitment things
like fat twitch versus slow twitch
muscle fibers etc but even if it was
true that having more muscle
automatically meant you're stronger it
wouldn't necessarily follow that taller
people would therefore be stronger
that's because the size of your bone is
not the only factor determining how much
muscle you've got on it another
important factor is your muscle belly to
tendon ratio so if you take these biceps
the part of the muscle belly is the part
of Survivor you know there's actually
the bicep it's the muscle but your upper
arm is not entirely covered in muscle is
also covered in tendon the tendon is
what attaches the biceps to the arm so
some of that space is taken up by
muscles and some of it is taken up by
tendon if you have a very long pendant
that we use less space for your muscles
this is a poor muscle to tenderly shape
on the other hand oh yeah very short
tendon then you have space for more
muscle on the bone so it's not just
about how long the bone is but also how
much of it is covered in muscle you
could be very tall you could be all
tendon and I'm taught most of us know
people in life who are kind of very tall
and lanky and all sinuan and that's
partly probably why another factor that
influences on your strength there's kind
of legend to size but not directly is
the labour arm so if you think of bicep
curls again as I'm telling a dumbbell so
my biceps here which is supplying force
and tacking by the tendon to the forearm
the length of the forearm is going to
influence how much pressure how much
power I need to observe in order to move
the dumbbell the longer the arm the more
strength I actually need in order to
move it because it's further away from
the axis of rotation where the muscle is
attaching these ways think about this is
to imagine digging with a spade
everything with a spade in the garden
you're trying to lift a big chunk of
dirt but they are at the end of the
stage where the actual shovel end is so
you need to find more force
from that end in order to leaver the
dirt up if the stages shorter you can
lift the same amount dirt more easily so
actually in this scenario having a
longer forearm would be detrimental to
your performance because you need to
apply more strengths because you have a
longer lever arm this is not just true
bicep curls is true in all sorts of
different exercises where the ratios of
your limbs and your torso all play this
role so it's for instance if you're
doing squat then you actually want to
shorter legs for the simple reason that
you're going closer to the ground you
can miss more weight for more
repetitions because you're not traveling
as far and it's doing deadlift then you
actually want shorter legs and a longer
arm because the long arms can make up
some of the distance so you have to
squat down less far this is also why you
shouldn't teach everybody in the gym
using the same technique because
depending on the shape of their body and
their natural ratio the proportion
they're going to perform better in some
ways than other people will so listen to
your body because your body knows
intuitively how it should move and what
you get from a book isn't necessarily
going to take to account the different
proportions to your joints and bones and
limb length though suddenly you'd ignore
your trainer will he tell you to stop
arching your back during a deadlift or a
squat but it doesn't mean you need to
take into account that was right for you
wouldn't society be right for someone
else and you need to find your own
optimal way of moving and that's not
even all of it another factor to
consider is your tendon insertion the
tendon insertion is the point at which
attended attaches to the bone reasons
we've got very long for on this could be
mitigated somewhat if the insertion is
further along the meaning that the
actual lever arm is shorter of course
you wouldn't have an insertion of here
let me get my point so yeah there are
far more factors involved in strength
and performance than just your height
you've also got the amount of muscle
you've got compared to your tendons
you've got well-attended and surf you've
got the proportions of your different
lever arms and limbs so you could be
very tall and very lanky and covered in
tendon or you can be very short and
compact and powerful you'll also be
short and packaged with tendon and very
you know
there's all kind of different
combinations you've got to play the hand
you're dealt you've got to emphasize
your strengths and bring up your
weaknesses
you've got to find into techniques that
are best for you and just what you've
got because these are genetic factors
you can't change what you can do is to
increase muscle size through hypertrophy
increase the multiplier recruitment and
just make yourself the best version of
what you've been given so examines
interesting useful guides if you did
please consider leaving a like and share
really helps me out when you do you can
even comment down below and I'll try and
get back to you you can also follow me
on social media on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram I post most my workouts there
and all kinds of other stuff and of
course stay tuned if you want more
videos on working out on brain training
productivity technology fitness
performance etc you name it
it'll be here thanks so much for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now